[Music]
we're welcoming the chief operating
officer of Bitcoin to help explain just
what bitcoin is and how it works so
please welcome Marcus Ortman let's get
him in here Thank You Conan okay Marcus
I'm glad you're here because I've asked
a lot of people and no one's been able
to explain what bitcoin is all about
Conan it's quite simple bitcoin is a
decentralized digital currency exchanged
in the interactive Metaverse yeah that
didn't help me at all okay I mean is it
like PayPal no no here let me put it in
layman's terms bitcoin is an open-source
synergistic flow matrix facilitating
each transference of digital assets no
those are not layman's terms can you
just explain how I might use Bitcoin
okay
Conan imagine that you are in a snow
globe where every snowflake is a unique
and beautiful coin portunity no no I'm
that didn't help me at all can you tell
me what bitcoin is or not bitcoin is a
flat circle and everything we ever do or
have ever done we will do again that's a
line from true detective
fine fine Kona and I think all of your
questions about Bitcoin can be answered
with this brief informational video
right thank you
[Music]
okay that was [ __ ]
one last time do you know what bitcoin
is yes I do it is this the smoke really
did nothing to hide his escape he's
Morrison he needs a lot more smoke